you can make this hey now like you've
noticed by the way I have left but hey
unfinished
let me try what's going on right see
this journey that we've been going what
this is in the last few days okay
we've met very very simple equations and
then we've gradually made the more
complicated now I want to call your mind
back to this analogy I gave you the
meaning of HS solve equations is just
like chess you're trying to get the king
the king by himself and that's what it
means to solve the equation right just
like in chess you get Q by himself and
then you could with the game okay but
there are lots of different kinds of
pieces on the chessboard just like there
are lots of different ways we can
introduce numbers and operations to sort
of guard the King right now for instance
you might hopefully recognize because I
put some real effort into this one right
this is a knight okay Knights of special
because since they ride on horses they
can jump over other pieces right they do
care pieces of the way they just go
straight through them as if they were
there just like a boss here okay so when
you're a chess player and you're
learning how to work with these pieces
and you know get rid of them you need
different strategies right so different
kinds of numbers are all operations are
just like different pieces so I'm going
to introduce you what to you today we're
gonna solve equations with brackets now
you've met brackets before you met
brackets under order of operations okay
so we're just going to work with them in
the context of equations let's have a
look at this first example and here's a
question point it's actually the first
question from the exercise so I'm gonna
do this one for free okay this is what
we're going to solve and yes it starts
off easy you won't get more complicated
later on okay now what do we do is
you've got your brackets
and what do we what can we do with
brackets right would be a brace yep yeah
we do brackets first right when I get
rid of these brackets what's that corn
starts with a need to get rid of the
brackets what I usually call that is
expanding do you remember that okay see
you remember this right so what I want
to do is get rid of my brackets I'll
just wait till everyone's ready
I'm expand brackets get rid of them like
this I've got this too it multiplies by
the X but it also multiplies by the
three that's kind of the bracket speed
right
whatever this is doing do to everything
in there right
so 2 times X how would I write bathroom
add to X we see times 3 that's just 6
now once I've written that down
nothing's happened to the right-hand
side once I've written that down this
looks just like the pros we looked at
before in fact it's almost identical to
number 2 that we did just a few minutes
ago so what might you suggest I do to
get close to the answer minus 6
I'll take away 6 from both sides that'll
be great you take away from here that
leaves you with 2x you take away from
the right-hand side that leaves you to
do one more line what should I do to
both sides what operation woman OH
almost this is a 2 x right two times so
I should do by I should divide both by 2
that gives me what now
that's great this is a good general
purpose strategy for solving any time
you see brackets just like rent and
suggestion without with order of
operations brackets are like the first
thing in order of operations so
expanding them is usually a safe way to
go however I want to give you an extra
tip okay I want you to write down this
question again you remember I showed you
before there's often many ways to solve
a question you can use different
strategies or you can use the same
strategies in different order sometimes
some better than others so I want to
look at this I want to suggest something
else we might do suppose I don't want to
expand the brackets first this might be
a good idea because do you see that both
sides right just like both sides he
armed right both sides are x 2 you see
that so from this line to this slide you
divided by 2 divide by 2 divide by 2
there's no reason I can't do that first
I can do that versus
the problem right what will happen to
the left-hand side when I divide this by
2 this is up two times right so that two
times you get eliminated by this / -
right
do it to the left do it to the right
okay so here these two will cancel
exactly right
cancel cancel so on the Left I'll just
get left with X plus 3 okay now what
happens on the right hand side 8 by 2 4
okay I really have one more step now how
do I get rid of that 3 on the left I'll
take away right take away from the left
and take away from the right just like
you expected okay now remember we're
seen before lots of different ways to do
this
which do you think is better what do you
reckon yeah okay
will you go for number one I think
there's good reasons you can say number
ones a good idea because we know how to
expand brackets and that's just like
normal order of operations
okay who beckons number two either what
do you reckon why um know what she's
probably better because if Unitarian
Oh No
this is true I actually if you just
compare the lines I know they're both
pretty quick right but this is just ever
so slightly quicker and in fact there's
a good reason why it's not just that it
looks like that when you expand right
you see how you two times when you
expand numbers get bigger numbers get
bigger right like if this number was
like 10 or 12 or something like that
all of these numbers would generally
increase the size so on this next line
I'm gonna have bigger numbers but when
you divide no let's not get bigger
numbers get smaller they get easier to
deal with usually okay so in this
question I mean both are fine
both end up at the right answer I'm
gonna do this second one okay I think
it's gonna get me the answer quicker
it's not like I have any fractions or
anything like that but I have both tools
in my disposal okay so let's just review
okay expanding brackets that's a safe
option and always work but sometimes we
divide first I make this really really
simple for you I look how easy those
numbers are okay